[Música]
economía y comenzamos aquí en directo
américa este bloque hablando de europa
porque puedes respirar tranquila por lo
menos parcialmente jorge porque rusia va
a comenzar nuevamente a bombear gas
desde sus diferentes pozos así es bueno
el este gasoducto el norte uno
precisamente estuvo suspendido durante
diez días por mantenimiento pero al
reanudar operaciones lo hará en torno al
30 por ciento de su capacidad cuando
termine su periodo de mantenimiento
según dijeron las autoridades de
alemania alemania alega que no es lo
acordado' contractualmente pero que es
peor que nada persistían también las
preocupaciones allí de que rusia
prolongará el mantenimiento con italia y
alemania ya que occidente advierte que
podría ser utilizado como pretexto por
moscú para enviar menos gas a europa y
presionar políticamente vladimir putin
también aseguró que la capacidad del
gasoducto que se había reducido al 40
por ciento antes de este mantenimiento
podría reducirse aún más debido a la
lentitud de los trabajos de
mantenimiento de los equipos y seguimos
hablando de rusia porque el banco
central de este país parece que está
comenzando a flexibilizar un poco su
política monetaria
es que el emisor ahora dijo que va a
permitir a los bancos de los países no
amistosos como llaman a todos los países
de occidente que han impuesto sanciones
contra rusia a negociar entre las
divisas en los mercados de divisas rusos
del banco también eliminó el límite del
30 por ciento de los pagos por
adelantado a los no residentes en los
contratos de importación de algunos
servicios parte de los controles
monetarios que había introducido después
de la guerra en ucrania rusia presionó a
su sector financiero para alejarse del
dólar estadounidense el euro y otras
monedas de países que han impuesto
sanciones contra ellos pero la caída de
las importaciones las restricciones al
comercio y la masiva retirada de divisas
disparó el rublo la moneda local esto
hace replantear a los responsables
políticos que afirman que la fortaleza
de la moneda está perjudicando a la
industria del país y ha llevado al banco
a recortar los tipos de interés ya
levantar algunas restricciones como las
que mencionábamos lo mencionábamos jorge
en el bloque de noticias del día que en
estados unidos el presidente joe biden
prometió medidas contra el cambio
climático profundizamos en el tema bueno
baiden prometió seguir trabajando para
aprobar estas medidas frente a lo que
considera una inyección del congreso
bardem anunció que su voz invertirá 2300
millones de dólares a combatir el calor
extremo y otros efectos de las crisis
climáticas las acciones fueron
anunciadas luego de que el senador
demócrata joe manchin se negara a la
semana pasada a aprobar un ambicioso
paquete legislativo que incluye millones
de dólares en inversiones verdes este
anuncio se da también cuando europa se
enfrenta a una histórica ola de calor
que deja récord de temperatura en reino
unido y también agrava estos incendios
forestales que mencionábamos
anteriormente en francia y españa- y
pasemos ahora a hablar de la industria
automotriz la empresa ford planea
despedir a mil personas para financiar
entonces su incursión en el mercado de
los vehículos eléctricos área en la que
está bastante atrás bueno ocho mil
empleados según bloomberg es lo que
despedirá por los despidos se
producirían en la recién creada unidad
for blood responsable de la producción
de vehículos con motores de combustión
interna así como en otras operaciones de
la empresa la medida sería un paso
importante en el plan del consejero
delegado jim farley de recortar tres mil
millones de dólares en costos para el
año 2026 por actualmente empleado 132
mil trabajadores en todo eeuu y es ahí
donde se espera mayor parte de estos
recortes y pasemos a américa latina' la
actividad económica en la argentina
creció 74 por ciento interanual para el
mes de mayo qué significa esto es la
decimoquinta subida interanual
consecutiva los datos del instituto
nacional de estadísticas y censos que
son un anticipo provisional para medir
la variación trimestral del producto
interno bruto reflejan que ahí hubo una
aceleración respecto al ritmo de
crecimiento interanual que se había
registrado en marzo pasado después de
tres años de una severa recesión
agravada por la pandemia 19 la economía
argentina logró recuperarse el año
pasado en torno al 10,4 por ciento pero
según el acuerdo firmado con el fondo
monetario internacional argentina deberá
crecer este año entre un 3,5 y un 4,2
por ciento pasemos a los indicadores
aquí en la mitad de la semana hoy
miércoles como las ffaa las principales
bolsas en el mundo bueno empezamos con
wall street que cerró en verde animada
sobre todo por la subida de las
tecnológicas gracias a las buenas
expectativas generadas por los
resultados de netflix y otras empresas
de ese sector en europa las acciones
terminaron a la baja debido a la
incertidumbre en torno al suministro de
gas en la región y el futuro del primer
ministro italiano mario draghi en
américa latina la bolsa mexicana cayó
por las consultas de eeuu a méxico sobre
las medidas que el gobierno ha
implementado en el mercado energético y
que podrían violar inclusive el tratado
de libre comercio con estados unidos y
canadá conocido como tema siempre del
día sorprenda mejor g bueno es una mala
cifra 500 millones de dólares a eso
ascienden las pérdidas por las protestas
en panamá según la cámara de comercio de
panamá fedecámarás sorprendentes cifras
gracias muchas gracias jorge punto final
en la economía a continuación el debate
aquí en directo américa
[Música]